je pourrais plus le payer maintenant moi
tu étais pris mon jeu c'est parce qu'il
est remarqué que depuis quelques temps
on parle beaucoup dans la littérature
dans le cinéma on parle beaucoup
d'érotisme excusez moi quand on parle
d'un film éducatif en général c'est un
film d'éducation sexuelle
alors j'ai pensé qu'on laisse se
rajeunir d'une quinzaine d'années et
revenir aux sources en parlant du du
précurseur de ce genre de littérature
qui était le dr kinsey si j'étais
détaché auprès de vous par les
professeurs quincey rapport au corps à
corps qui cause des rapports et à foin
difficile à dire que ça va des fois
quand ça vous travaillez entre les bons
en mêlée bonne formule
le coeur à faire là dessus il en est un
qui sait c'est qu'un seul votre maison
peut prendre caisse
c'est un truc machin qui fait que ce
n'est pas facile a bien non quant à
bonal devant une bonne femme
il se dit avec préméditation une bergère
ça écoute réparé avant et qui est de ce
côté là peuvent amasser 10 ans sauf à
l'intérieur la mire encore une fois tant
que champion de la galipette
vous connaissez la suite jetant par
dessus le radeau de la méduse jusque là
viol dans les plumes param param lâcher
les chiens et toujours ce prix comme
disait ma grand mère qui a lu jj bien
dans l'ensemble
l'homme aime ça la femme aime ça même
moi qui ai au cool
sans être cavaleur je dois avouer que ça
m'est arrivé aussi et te demande pas une
fois en 37 à l'exposition en sortant du
palais de la découverte
deux fois en 40 c'était la débâcle une
fois en 44 pour arroser pour arroser la
victoire et même plus récemment et sans
raison valable
en sortant du salon de l'automobile je
me suis mal conduit et depuis je me suis
vu fréquemment pratiqué toutes deux une
fois en hiver une fois hors du terrain
pour la lutte en perramant où on an'a
pas mais jusqu'aux jeux cousu recousu
cous et je suis sûr que dans la salle ce
soir il y en a parmi vous
qu'ils sont des pratiquants de la chose
car comme dit qui c'est qui ne sait qui
lui sait on n'est pas de bois et pour
ceux d'entre vous qui sera un peu
demeuré qui suivrait difficilement je
vous causez statistiques comme l'a dit
qu'à celle des statistiques cause 50%
des bonnes femmes américaines ont reçu
des propositions malhonnêtes avant l'âge
de la compétition 60 % trouvent qu'on
s'embête pas dans le lit du conjoint 40%
que 6 et que c'est la faute du bonhomme
pascal un manque de présence de fermeté
d'entousiasme est assez bon homme je le
redis du talent total si tu veux parce
que quand on te marie pas se mentir à
30% des bonnes femmes aiment mieux aller
au cinéma qu d'avoir 10 heures gratuites
à la maison mais 70% se contente de
ladite séance engrais temps ça reste pas
permanents ont commandé un bon nombre de
bonhomme qui s'embêtent pas de grosses
bonnes femmes et je voudrais maintenant
mais tendre c'est une image
je les appellerai de sujets d'élite
particulièrement portée sur la chose
trois beaux hommes sur cent pensent qu'à
ça et embête tout le temps leur bonne
femme cela paraisse cus coup pour l'un à
l'ombre et son lapin ça l'air froid dit
si bonnes femmes sur 100 sont des
virtuoses les petits prodiges et ça te
grande part tout avait-elle carnac donné
j'en ai connu une de virtuoses on va
retrouver la tête en bas raccrocher aux
rideaux les doigts de pied en éventail
nous on serait bien rendre les da quant
à 15 sec qui lui sait il relate une dame
américaine championne des les grandes
manoeuvres qui dit qu'elle est montée
cent fois au septième ciel en 1h
régalerez succulence peut-être mais
étonnement de ma part ou c'était une
chatouilleuse où son mari est garçon
d'ascenseur
quant aux bonnes femmes qui vous disent
je suis frais vide 1 ça dépend de quel
bois se chauffe et je voudrais conclure
sur la france des andes herbe monsieur
la guardia experts de new york
si tu n'en veux pas je la remets ça
mange pas de pain ça mange pas